la primera vez que la oposición
brasileña se junta y sale a las calles
casi un mes después de las grandes
manifestaciones a favor de jair
bolsonaro el presidente brasileño que
había pronunciado un discurso
antidemocrático que preocupó la
comunidad internacional y las
instituciones brasileñas
los manifestantes bajan en las calles de
las principales ciudades del país como
aquí en el centro del río de janeiro
vivir en todos la destitución inmediata
del presidente brasileño que acusan de
haber llevado el país a una crisis
y económica sin precedentes
[Música]
porque ha hecho un trabajo terrible en
el manejo de la pandemia con más de
medio millón de brasileños muertos es
negacionista es culpable por la falta de
trabajo el desempleo los precios altos
todo esto es el resultado de una persona
que no tiene la menor capacidad de ser
presidente y necesitamos deshacernos de
bolsonaro tener elecciones así que
hagamos lo
repudiamos lo que dijo bolsonaro en la
onu repudiamos todas las mentiras que
dijo allí la realidad es que brasil está
pasando hambre está desempleado y
necesita una nueva política
[Música]
las disculpas de izquierdas
ahora no es el momento de disputas
insignificantes es el momento de
mantenerse firmes unidos y pensar en
brasil es hora de deshacerse evolucionar
somos la mayoría de la gente en las
calles las calles son nuestras
muchos de los manifestantes presentes
hoy ponen dos de sus esperanzas en la
posible candidatura del ex presidente
luís nuevas o lula da silva para
oponerse al fair perdonar en las
próximas elecciones presidenciales pero
lula no va a todos los votos una gran
parte de la oposición en nabucco lanzada
en uno de los numerosos escándalos de
corrupción estudiando en la clase
política brasileña
agassi son mayoría de las próximas
elecciones presidenciales la oposición
brasileña sigue muy dividida